how's it going my bro and sisters my
name is Pierre de Paz today I'm going to
make video on how to get started on
YouTube I've been asked to make this
video I don't know how many times I get
this question all the time can you give
me some tips on how to get started I
think what I always just say keep keep
working hard and I'm sure you will
succeed but I thought not today I wanted
to actually give something more
constructive and some some more help
than just that I've been doing a lot of
streams lately and everyone is keep
asking me how do I get started what kind
of tips do you have and I thought ok
fine I'll make it okay I thought about
making this video before many times but
I just feel like Who am I to tell you
how to it's not like I know all the
answers and I really think everyone has
a different answer to the question on
how to grow on YouTube so just take this
as from my own perspective also know
that I don't know everything and just
because I say something doesn't mean
it's the rule of thumb you know that is
it that's not the case couldn't be
further from it and I started YouTube
seven years ago so obviously things are
different now this video probably won't
be relevant for most people watching but
maybe it will be interesting I don't
know
here we go first of all I want to start
on the equipment because I think if this
is where most people fail right away I
see so many people get really angry
about this one because they bought all
this expensive equipment and they come
to me like what are the subscribers
where are all the beauty I got I spent
all this money on all this equipment I
always say don't spend money on
equipment it doesn't have to be
expensive at all and I think a lot of
people wait with starting videos because
they don't have all the equipment I
think it takes practice to make videos
and I think it doesn't hurt to get
started with what you have I didn't have
a webcam when I started I had a [ __ ]
I'm legit use this microphone which I
actually accidentally broke that's my
first microphone on the razer headphones
and it was fine
it's really what it definitely doesn't
hurt to have nice quality don't get me
wrong but it's not automatically going
to make you get subscribers I'm going to
link what I think is a good sort of
budget start up in case you're curious
of what sort of equipment I would
recommend if you want to start making my
type of videos and I'll also link my
equipment in case you're curious what
exactly it is I use stand out personally
I'm very much drawn to two different
things that people do if I notice the
channel doing something I haven't seen
before
I'm automatically more drawn to that
thing and I think it was the same thing
for me when I started making videos I
did what everyone else was doing I I did
Call of Duty videos because that's what
was popular at the time but that's what
made me want to start making YouTube
videos because I loved watching it on
YouTube and it was really popular back
then and I enjoyed making those type of
videos but my channel didn't grow from
it at all I had like what a couple
hundred people watching me and I
remember when other youtubers refer
themself to it oh yeah I only had a
couple hundred back then I'm like never
a hundred I'm so [ __ ] proud of these
hundred people that I have shut the [ __ ]
up and I also remember watching all
these bigger youtubers doing the same
Call of Duty videos and I'm like these
guys are [ __ ] terrible I'm Way better
than these guys
why is my channel not growing more but
that's the thing the big ones have
already settled in you know you're not
going to it's going to be hard as hell
you have you have an uphill battle and
it wasn't until I started doing
something different something that
hadn't been done before like the horror
videos that's when I started to get an
audience that really cared about the
content that I was making it and it was
so clear and I really see it myself when
why I discovered you youtubers it's
always something different they have
something different what was it dr. Dre
said it's easy to make it to the top but
it's twice as hard to stay there you see
people on YouTube come and go all the
time I don't want to throw any names out
there but you know what I mean like
there's a ton of youtubers that everyone
used to watch and every day I got so
many so much attention but they just
didn't have what it takes to keep their
audience a lot of people sort of get
boosted from the algorithm of you
to basically YouTube recommend certain
type of videos that fit what they want
to promote maybe it's really long videos
maybe it's videos they get a lot of
likes and a lot of this and that and
there's always people that abuse their
algorithm it's been since I started on
YouTube and it's still going on is this
something that well I don't think will
ever end and it's really unfair because
a lot of big a lot a lot of youtubers
get really big really fast because of it
but basically they go away equally fast
if you don't have something to maintain
your audience with something more than
your stick of making algorithm happy
then your lifespan on YouTube is going
to be short that's just how it is so I'm
not really too bothered by it about any
of it I just don't want you if you want
to grow your channel to be obsessed
about the algorithm because that
shouldn't be the number one priority I
personally never try to abuse the
algorithm or some [ __ ] like that
honestly I had no idea what I was doing
literally I discovered that ten minutes
videos like a year ago with me remember
the reply girls you know they were so
[ __ ] popular they got so many views
because they the algorithm promoted
their videos in the sidebar all the time
but it's not like anyone is still
watching them like oh I wonder what this
aliens was what this boob girl is saying
now about this you know what I'm getting
with this is you needed personality
people people will find your video but
they're not going to say and like they
care about you as a person I think
YouTube is all about personality at
least that's how I see it and anyone I
watch on YouTube I watch because I care
about their personality I care about
them more than just their content but
also who they are as a person and that's
why I enjoy watching them and that's why
I enjoy YouTube I enjoy because it's
different than television you're not
just watching this product behind a
bunch of producers and writers you're
watching just a person speak directly
into a camera and I think that's the
beauty of it I also think that's why so
many youtubers come and go they forget
about this part and that's fine you know
it's not like everything has to be super
personal and everything has to be
fillable I love you guys so much you're
my
family YouTube is a hobby and a job at
the same time which can be really hard
to balance I think a lot of people don't
realize this but you get to set your own
hours you get to set your own pace
but it basically means you'll be working
24/7 like it's really hard to turn off
YouTube in your brain I'm always
checking videos how are they doing I'm
always checking stats I'm always
checking comments what are people saying
what are people thinking and it's really
hard to turn off it's not like a
nine-to-five job you go in you do your
job okay now I'm done who I can relax I
really struggle a lot with this and just
trying to shut my brain off and okay now
I'm doing this now I'm doing that and
that's why I really enjoy having an
office because I can do my work here and
then once I'm back home I can just relax
it's I guess my advice here is to try
and separate it I treat you to riddle
with a lot of respect because I feel so
lucky to be in the situation that I am I
think a lot of youtubers take take
YouTube very casually I'll just upload a
video I need some money I'll upload a
video maybe I'm a little naive for
saying that but I always get the
question what happens if you miss a day
Felix what's the big deal who's gonna
care it's okay you don't have to upload
all the time but it's like I set the
schedule for me I know I can do it that
is my job to do it still I have to do it
okay
I see YouTube as a it's not going to
last forever but I might as well make
the most of it meanwhile every youtuber
has a life span market yourself most
youtubers that you are watching got a
helping hand to get where they are maybe
they don't admit it maybe I'm just wrong
most youtuber had some helping hand
maybe maybe they maybe their videos was
posted on a website you know that that's
not okay this is a cool video
maybe you got trending on reddit you
know maybe you're a family member was
the youtuber or maybe a friend of you
of that person was a youtuber they
helped them getting that helping hand on
YouTube it's not essential but if it
makes use of easy mode pretty much so
already the hardest part of YouTube is
to establish your very first audience if
you can get that for free from someone
else hell yeah hell yeah that's the best
but I see a lot of misunderstanding of
this as well because for example I did
the shout out competition in the past
and for example Jack was one of them ken
was one of them and a lot of people look
at them and we like oh oh you got a
shout out from PewDiePie oh oh that's so
[ __ ] if I had one I would be big
[ __ ] you no that's not how it works a
shout I can only get you so far
it gets you that that bass audience
maybe but they're not going to stay
unless you're worthwhile staying -
they're not going to care about watching
any more videos unless you offload
videos unless you upload videos that
people care about you don't need a shout
out and a shout out isn't necessarily
going to help you unless your content is
interesting that is how it is
you see people all the time in my
comment section marketing their own
YouTube channel I find it very
disrespectful to do that it annoys the
hell out of me
because it's basically just ignoring
what I worked on and basically just
saying hey look at me I do think you
should market yourself somehow if you
really care about growing your channel
now I don't know what the best method is
but everyone has a secret
I'm sure of how they try to get their
channel out there maybe something
they're ashamed of that they wouldn't
admit I think most youtubers have it I
for example used to find commenters on
video similar to mine and I would write
a private message to them being like hey
I see that you enjoyed this channel
maybe you will enjoy mine
I know extremely embarrassing extremely
pathetic what I used to do it at least
it's not intrusive on someone else's
work okay so I recommend marketing
yourself somehow I just don't and it's
nothing shameful about doing it but
don't be [ __ ] obnoxious and
disrespectful doing it
that's my point with that next up is
don't [ __ ] trust anyone growing my
channel on YouTube I've come across so
many toxic people people that just want
your audience your subscribers they
don't give a [ __ ] about you they'll lie
to you they'll try and manipulate you I
think I'm one of my best skills as a
human being is to cut out toxic people I
have very little tolerance for people in
general and if I find them to be abusive
or disrespectful I have no problem with
cutting up these people in my life I
know some people really struggle with
this and I think as a youtuber you're
just really gonna have to be cut and dry
with people it's just how it is networks
you may have heard of networks a lot I'm
I'm technically signed up with the
network still but I'm not planning to
stay with the network
YouTube wouldn't sign with gaming
channels you could not monetize their
videos if you were a gaming channel back
in the day it was the worst thing I
think that could possibly happen to the
gaming community on YouTube because
essentially networks got so much power
because we were obligated to sign with
them so basically as a gamer you would
get these insanely bad deals with
networks where they would give you half
of your revenue and give you essentially
nothing back networks still take a huge
portion of your revenue if you're a
small youtuber I still get a lot of
people asking me hey I'm a youtuber I
should I sign up to the network I don't
know blah blah blah or do they increase
my CPM blah blah blah most likely they
don't from my experience they don't sell
ads on your videos think about most
networks they have like what thousands
of channels in them why would they care
about your channel you know how are they
going to focus on all these channels it
just doesn't make any sense
I would not recommend signing with the
network if I was a smaller youtuber
these days that's being said never
definitely helped me to a certain degree
but I think it's a smaller channel it's
completely useless they're just going to
take a portion of your revenue and give
you nothing back you're not obligated to
sign with the network
more so I would recommend against if
you're a smaller channel which brings me
to my next point get a lawyer don't sign
anything without professional / a
professional overlooking what you're
doing I signed contract severs that led
me into month-long processes of trying
to get out of those contracts it's a lot
cheaper to have a lawyer look over the
contract and knowing exactly what you're
getting yourself into
then afterwards get a lawyer to try and
get you out of this situation get a
lawyer and get an accountant if you're
if you were making money off youtube and
do it darling
I think setting those two things up
earlier is better than later I realize
this is a lot of information but I think
I saw this as the sort of me talking to
myself in the past and the sort of stuff
that I learned through this years of
making videos on YouTube and I try to
keep it as the actual advice and
constructive as possible but I would
like to finish with make YouTube with
the right intention I see so many people
wanting to make youtube videos because
they want to get famous they want to
make money which is all great stuff and
YouTube really is an amazing place for
it for that but make youtube videos
because you enjoy making them if you
don't enjoy making them you're not going
to keep making them you're just going to
fall off at some point and you're going
to get frustrated that it didn't turn
out the way you wanted it to be if you
make videos that you enjoy making it
then you can't lose it doesn't matter if
you don't get a lot of subscribers Asia
like I was equally happy when I had a
couple hundred subscribers I thought
that was the equally fun just to have
some people watching them if you make
videos that you enjoy making other
people will enjoy watching them I really
really strongly believe in that so if
you're not enjoying making videos then
don't make videos I hope this was
helpful I'm not I'm not sure to be
honest if it was but I hope it was
interesting at least I don't know I
don't know here you go
I did the video finally leave a like my
sister fixers
and state history